[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend nun also doch
gestern hieß es noch aus dem Weißen Haus
die USA liefern der Ukraine erstmal
keine attackens Raketen keine 24 Stunden
später erreicht uns die überraschende
Nachricht die Marschflugkörper die eine
Reichweite von bis zu 300 km haben soll
nun doch geliefert werden was sind die
Hintergründe und vor allen Dingen auch
was sind die Folgen fragen wir nach in
Berlin und Washington einen schönen
guten Abend an euch beide in die
Hauptstädte beginnen wir bei MRT Wissen
stand denn das mit der Lieferung gestern
schon fest und heute ist das irgendwie
durchgesickert oder was ist da los
da stand es tatsächlich gestern schon
fest denn in der Tat hat Joe Biden
offenbar wohl oder mir silensky bei
seinem Besuch gestern im Weißen Haus
genau das gesagt dass die USA bereit
sind attackens zu liefern und nach
zdf-informationen wurden schon vor Tagen
auch Verbündete in Europa darüber
informiert das heißt eine
Grundsatzentscheidung ist gefallen es
geht eben um diese weitreichenden
Raketen 300 km Reichweite und man wird
ganz offen bei Atems liefern die schon
etwas älter sind
ältere Bestände und das sind Raketen die
bestückt sind mit Streumunition das
heißt auf denen dann eben einige hundert
von kleinen Sprengkörpern noch sind so
dass wenn man ins Zielgebiet kommt diese
Sprengkörper freigesetzt werden damit
man Ziele noch besser bekämpfen kann und
das betrifft ganz besonders die
Flugabwehr oder die Luftabwehr Russlands
auf der Krim beispielsweise der
russischen Streitkräfte aber auch weit
hinter der Frontlinie dann
Nachschublinien zu treffen und das will
man tun jetzt vor Beginn des Winter
jetzt schauen wie man mit der Offensive
noch ein Stück weiter vorankommt und
auch verhindert dass in diesem Winter
vor allen Dingen von der Krim eben
Raketen von russischer Seite
abgeschossen werden
offiziell ist das noch nicht bestätigt
worden das hängt vielleicht damit
zusammen dass man noch nicht entschieden
hat wie viele von diesen attackens man
genau an die Ukraine geliefert und waren
sie geliefert werden also Verbündete in
Europa wurden informiert damit natürlich
auch Deutschland dann fragen wir nach
bei Theo call in Berlin Theo die
Reichweite der Marschflugkörper das soll
ja die Sorge von Kanzler Scholz sein
daher das Zögern auch bei Taurus ist der
Kanzler da jetzt unter Zugzwang
ja sicher aber höherer Druck heißt nicht
unbedingt dass damit auch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Taurus
Lieferung steigt in der öffentlichen
Debatte wird ja bisher fälschlicherweise
immer in Vergleich zur Lieferung der
Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer gezogen damals hat
Berlin ja so lange gezögert bis man
quasi im Gleichschritt mit Washington
vorgehen konnte also am Ende dann Joe
Biden seine US-Panzer lieferte hat dann
auch der Kanzler ja gesagt im Fall der
Kurzstreckenraketen aber ist die Lage in
einem entscheidenden Punkt anders und
das ist weniger die Frage der Reichweite
denn da wäre man ja jetzt im Einklang
mit den USA viel mehr müsste Deutschland
für den Einsatz der Taurus
Marschflugkörper eigene Geodaten liefern
also Zieldaten oder ähnliches und das
würde bedeuten eigene Experten vor Ort
was niemand will oder digitale
Zusammenarbeit aus der Ferne und beides
wird von den Entscheidern hier in Berlin
als sehr nah an der roten Linie gesehen
dann selbst Konfliktpartei zu werden
Briten und Franzosen die ja ihre
Marschflugkörper schon geliefert haben
die gehen damit offensichtlich
entspannter um also der öffentliche und
politische Druck auf die Ampel dürfte
durch die us-entscheidung weiter steigen
aber ich würde eher erwarten dass die
Bundesregierung erstmal andere Lieferung
verstärkt statt Taurus sind wir gespannt
auf die nächsten Tage da wird die
Debatte sicherlich in Deutschland dann
weitergeführt vielen Dank nach
Washington und nach Berlin für eure
Einschätzung
und wir schauen jetzt auf die
Migrationsdebatte liegt es am Wahlkampf
in Hessen und Bayern oder ist es doch
Einsicht jedenfalls sagen jetzt auch
parteiübergreifend Bundespolitiker und
nicht nur Kommunalpolitiker wir haben
die Belastungsgrenze erreicht so kann es
nicht weitergehen das also was passieren
muss da sind sich offenbar die meisten
einig aber was genau passieren soll da
gehen die Meinungen auseinander die
Ideen zur Begrenzung so alt wie die
Probleme mehr Grenzkontrollen Sachstand
Geldleistungen sozialstandard senken und
so weiter neue schnell umsetzbare und
effektive Ideen wären eigentlich gut
aber die hat Nicole Diekmann heute in
Berlin kaum gehört
hier stand vor rund zwei Wochen der
Kanzler und warb für einen Pakt für
Deutschland nur gemeinsam könne man so
den Mehltau vom Lande abschütteln
Adressat im Hohen Haus vor allem die
Union während er Scholz aber vor allem
um bürokratieabbauging legen CDU und CSU
nun einen sogenannten migrationspakt für
Deutschland vor und nutzten die heutige
Debatte für scharfe Attacken gegen die
bundesinnenministerin lassen sie uns
neue Maßnahmen vereinbaren in Europa ist
Frau Feser bei der Migrationspolitik
kein Zug fährt sondern sie sind das
trojanische Pferd zu Verschärfung der
migrationskrise das ist die Situation
Flucht und Asyl eines der strittigsten
kompliziertesten Themenfelder der
Politik und wohl auch eines der
verfahrensten für neues war dazu heute
nicht zu hören dass aber in massiver
schärfer noch gut zweieinhalb Wochen bis
zur Landtagswahl in Bayern und in Hessen
dort kandidiert die
bundesinnenministerin als
Spitzenkandidatin und teilte heute
ihrerseits aus
sie reden von Europa ich hätte da was
verhindert lieber Herr Dobrindt ich weiß
in Europa die für die Bundesregierung es
geschafft hat den historischen
Durchbruch hinzubekommen dass wir
überhaupt eine Lösung haben einen
gemeinsames europäisches Asylsystem auf
dem Weg zu bringen das ist ja lächerlich
was sie hier machen sie haben es sich
hinbekommen wir haben es hinbekommen als
Bundesregierung noch ist dieses
Asylsystem allerdings nicht in Kraft und
in zumindest einem Punkt waren sich
heute alle einig Länder und Kommunen
sind am Anschlag unter anderem fordern
CDU und CSU deshalb das
abschiebekandidaten in Zukunft für 28
statt wie bisher für 10 Tage in
Gewahrsam genommen werden dürfen diesen
Vorschlag hat wäre sie allerdings auch
schon gemacht auch die Forderung Sache
statt Geldleistungen für Flüchtlinge
sorgt für Kritik wissen Sie was
Sachleistungen stehen doch längst im
Gesetz ich habe heute morgen noch mal
nachgezählt acht von 16 Innenministern
in Deutschland werden von der CDU und
der CSU gestellt warum fordern Sie uns
denn auf etwas zu etwas auf wofür sie
zuständig sind machen Sie es doch
einfach in den Ländern bestätigt sah
sich dagegen die in Teilen rechtsextreme
AFD was da im Papier stehe seinen
ursprünglich ihre Forderungen
die Panik der Union sieht man an ihrem
heutigen migrationsantrag sie machen
eine Wende um 180 Grad der einzige Grund
für den öffentlichen inszenierten
Richtungswechsel der CDU ist der Erfolg
der AFD
ein Pakt für Deutschland schon als der
Kanzler in vorschlug gab es Zweifel
ernst gemeintes Angebot oder PR-Nummer
heute haben sich diese Zweifel erhärtet
Inhalt aber auch Ton machen ein paar
Tieren schwer vorstellbar
Innenministerin Feiser hatte es ja hier
im heute-journal bereits angedeutet
jetzt hat sie es angekündigt sie will
stationäre Grenzkontrollen zu Polen und
Tschechien prüfen lassen das Bundesamt
für Migration und Flüchtlinge hat im
laufenden Jahr bis einschließlich August
rund
205.000 Erstanträge auf Asyl registriert
das ist eine Zunahme um über 77% im
Vergleich zum Vorjahreszeitraum zudem
sind seit Kriegsbeginn über eine Million
Menschen aus der Ukraine zu uns
geflüchtet soweit die nackten Zahlen die
zu einer Überforderung werden weil man a
die geflüchteten menschenwürdig
unterbringen möchte weil es B genügend
Integrationsangebote braucht und C
ausreichend Plätze in Kitas und Schulen
um mal nur drei Punkte zu nennen und bei
allen dreien ist bei vielen Kommunen die
Leistungsfähigkeit ausgeschöpft das
führt dazu dass die Stimmung in Teilen
singt und die Wut steigt Eva Scheller
mit einem Beispiel aus Baden-Württemberg
sie wollen uns erstmal zeigen was der
Landkreis schon leistet
die Jugendherberge umfunktioniert zur
Flüchtlingsunterkunft obwohl Wohnraum
Mangelware ist schaffen sie allerorten
Platz für geflüchtete
die Möbel sind gespendet ehrenamtliche
helfen wo es geht aber jetzt kommt die
Botschaft von CDU Landrat Günter Martin
Pauly es geht nicht mehr ganz klar
wissen wir heute feststellen leider dass
die Stimmung schon länger gekippt ist es
wird immer mehr wir sind irgendwo auch
am Rande dem was wir leisten können was
wir verantwortungsbewusst leisten können
der Zollernalbkreis ländlich konservativ
wohlhabend typisch Baden-Württemberg mit
einer Besonderheit in einem Ort hier in
Burladingen regierte zwei Jahre lang ein
afd-bürgermeister der 2020
zurückgetreten ist genau da wird der
Landrat im Juli für eine weitere
Flüchtlingsunterkunft
das Video zeigt wie die Stimmung
eskaliert die Menschen setzen den
Landrat unter Druck
über mehrere Stunden entladen sich Wut
Hass Angst
[Musik]
betreuen kann ja und wir sind einfach
nicht gewillt unser Hab und Gut noch
verteidigen zu müssen
also ich war schon etwas überrascht ich
hätte nie geglaubt dass ich im Sommer
abkreis irgendwo mal sowas erleben muss
und das ist natürlich Spitze vom Eisberg
wohin also mit den angekündigten
geflüchteten öffentliche
Gemeinderatssitzungen Burladingen
gestern Abend der Druck auf den
mittlerweile amtierenden parteilosen
Bürgermeister ist groß er rettet sich
mit einem Appell an Berlin
setzen sie endlich die Brille der
Realität auf die Grenzen der
gesellschaftlichen Akzeptanz
sind erreicht es steht zu befürchten
dass dies die wertvollen Grundpfeiler
unserer Demokratie gefährdet die
geplante Flüchtlingsunterkunft lehnt die
Gemeinde ab wieder ein Platzproblem mehr
für Landrat pauli die Bundesregierung
muss diese Stimmung endlich ernst nehmen
fordert er weil die Überzeugungskraft
der überlasteten Kommunen auch tief im
Westen am Ende sei
was bringen Friedensmissionen wenn man
sich anschaut wie sich Mali in den
letzten zehn Jahren entwickelt hat kann
man unterm Strich sagen relativ wenig
das Land ist wieder zur Ruhe gekommen
noch hat sich die Situation für die
Menschen die nichts mit Militär kämpfen
Korruption zu tun haben wollen
verbessert und jetzt wird diese Mission
nach über 10 Jahren beendet allerdings
auf Druck der dortigen Militärregierung
das heißt auch für die Bundeswehr
Rückzug bzw Abzug und zwar bis zum Ende
des Jahres das ist nicht viel Zeit und
das Drumherum macht die Situation
tatsächlich auch nicht einfacher
zusammen von Lojewski war für uns in
Mali konkret in Gau im Osten des Landes
wo die meisten der rund 750 deutschen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten stationiert
sind
der Konflikt liegt in sichtweite die
Objektschützer der Bundeswehr können von
Ihrem Wachturm aus das Camp der
malischen Ami beobachten nur wenige
Meter weiter sollen die russischen
wagnertruppen sein die beiden Soldaten
waren erst kurz in Gao als sich
gegenüber islamistische
Selbstmordattentäter im Lager der Malia
in die Luft sprengten
erst hier grundsätzlich so dass es lange
ruhig ist und dann mal wieder ein
Zeichen gesetzt wird heißt grundsätzlich
rechnet man damit vor allem wenn man das
Land kennt aber für uns wir waren erst
17 Tage im Land dementsprechend das so
schnell wieder was passiert hätte keiner
von uns gedacht etwa 750 deutsche
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind noch in
gau-stationiert nahezu wöchentlich
werden es weniger und für die die bis
Ende des Jahres bleiben muss trotzdem
die Sicherheit garantiert werden
die Herausforderung ist unsere geordnete
Rückverlegung unserer Kräfte unseres
Materials
weil hier in Gau keine dreispurige
Autobahn nach Hause nach Deutschland
führt und das alles ganz schön ist nicht
trivial das Unterfangen das ganze
Material das ganze Personal was wir
haben geordnet nach Hause zu fühlen
geordnet heißt bei der Bundeswehr
sämtliches Material zu erfassen und
selbst die kleinen Teile zu
desinfizieren so schreibt es das Bundes
Tierseuchengesetz vor damit keine Keime
nach Deutschland gelangen die Ausrüstung
in einer Menge von 1000 Containern muss
über den kleinen Flughafen von Gau
ausgeflogen werden
in Afghanistan hatten wir einen dicken
großen Flugplatz hinten dran auf dem die
Antonov 124 landen konnte die schafft
wenn kalte Bedingungen sind über 100
Tonnen hier haben wir jetzt ein etwas
kleineren Flugplatz und haben hier
Maschinen die schaffen lediglich 20
Tonnen so das heißt also wir brauchen
hier viel viel mehr Flugzeuge um mehr
Material raus oder um Material raus zu
schaffen etwa 4 Milliarden Euro so
Schätzungen hat der Bundeswehreinsatz in
Mali gekostet schon jetzt ist klar und
ein Drittel des Materials geht nicht
zurück nach Deutschland auch wenn auf
dem Flughafen von Garo täglich mehrere
Transportmaschinen starten und landen
das Wetter und auch die malischen
Behörden Funken den Planungen zum
Rückzug immer wieder dazwischen dass
jeder heil nach Hause kommt dass meine
unsere erste Priorität unsere zweite
Priorität ist unsere Auftrag dass wir
unseren Auftrag sauber erfüllen die Zeit
läuft Ende des Jahres muss die
Bundeswehr raus sein aus der Wüste von
Mali Weihnachten in Deutschland das ist
jetzt das Ziel
[Musik]
und wir blicken jetzt in die Ukraine die
bei ihren Militäreinsätzen Erfolge
erzielt haben will und damit Heinz
beginnen deine Nachrichten ja die
Ukraine hat heute die Zentrale der
russischen Schwarzmeerflotte auf der
Krim attackiert im Hauptquartier in
Sebastopol auf der von Russland
annektierten Grimm brach ein Feuer aus
aus Moskau hieß es fünf Raketen sein
abgefangen worden kurze Zeit später soll
es einen massiven Cyberangriff auf
russische Internetdienstleister auf der
Krim gegeben haben
nach der Flutkatastrophe in Libyen fehlt
es den Menschen in den betroffenen
Gebieten weiter an sauberem Wasser
sanitären Einrichtungen und Unterkünften
das Deutsche Rote Kreuz hat vom
Flughafen Leipzig Halle Hilfsgüter auf
den Weg gebracht darunter eine
Trinkwasser Aufbereitungsanlage Liebe
und war vor knapp zwei Wochen von einem
Sturmtief erfasst worden es gab
verheerende Überschwemmungen laut
Weltgesundheitsorganisation wurden
bisher etwa 4000 Todesopfer
identifiziert
der frühere italienische
staatspräsidento Napolitano ist
gestorben im Alter von 98 Jahren in Rom
mit der Regierung mitteilte Napoletano
war zwischen 2006 und 2015 mehr als
achteinhalb Jahre Staatsoberhaupt
solange wie keine andere
syriens Machthaber Assad war jahrelang
international weitgehend isoliert jetzt
hat er mit Chinas Präsidenten Chi Chin
Bing einen wichtigen Verbündeten
getroffen beide Länder wollen in Zukunft
enger kooperieren und ihre Beziehungen
mit einer strategischen Partnerschaft
vertiefen hier sprach laut Staatsmedien
von einem historischen Meilenstein
schauen wir jetzt auf die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen sie
war ja hochgepriesen und ist dann tief
gefallen das frühe wm-haus in der
Vorrunde das gab es auch noch nie konnte
bisher noch nicht so richtig
aufgearbeitet werden da Trainerin Forst
Tecklenburg seitdem und bis heute
aufgrund einer Erkrankung fehlt der DFB
nimmt darauf Rücksicht der Spielplan
logischerweise nicht heute startete das
Team in die nations League nur über
diesen Wettbewerb kann das Ticket für
die Olympischen Spiele 2024 gezogen
werden ob der Auftakt gegen Dänemark
geglückt ist Jan döhling
die Co-Trainerin Britta Carson vertritt
die Chefin fürs Team geht es um ein
Olympiaticket und den Neuanfang die
deutschen Fußballfrauen in Dänemark
bemüht der Wille ist immer da aber es
fehlt wohl ein Qualität 23 Minute
Dänemark spielt schnell am Ende Rauch
gegen wangsgard und die mit
Durchsetzungsvermögen und dem Treffer
die Führung für die Däninnen zu Halbzeit
das DFB-Team dann besser nach dem
Wechsel aber erst Sydney Lohmann und
dann Alexandra Popp zu ungenau mit dem
Kopf besser machen es die Gastgeberin 64
Minute Dänemark aggressiv Bank Skat mit
ein bisschen Glück und ihrem zweiten Tor
froms bekommt den Tunnel bei allen
bemühen das deutsche Team auch in
Dänemark nicht auf der Höhe der Aufgabe
Fußball das Ergebnis Sport und wir
müssen vorne schießen damit man Spiel
gewinnen und dürfen keine kassieren und
das war heute nicht der Fall der Start
in die nations League also misslungen
jetzt fangen sie um die
Olympiaqualifikation
auch hinfallen aufstehen Krone rechten
weitermachen der Plan hat bei den Frauen
erst einmal nicht funktioniert
vielleicht funktioniert er ja aber bald
bei den Männern unter neuer Führung ab
heute ist es offiziell Julian nagelsmann
wird Coach der DFB-Elf und was für eine
Karriere im Februar 2016 übernahm er
Hoffenheim mit der fast aussichtslosen
Mission Klassenerhalt die meisterte er
mit gerade mal 28 nach seiner ersten
profi-trainerstation folgte dann Leipzig
und Bayern beim FC lief es ja nicht ganz
so gut sein frühzeitiger Abschied dort
erweist sich jetzt als gut für den DFB
so konnte der Verband in jedenfalls
verpflichten sieben Jahre nach dem Staat
seiner Trainerkarriere jetzt also
Bundestrainer und wieder hat er eine
Mission
ist gerade erwähnte ja Ziel im Sommer
eine sehr sehr gute Heime im zu spielen
ist extremer Anreiz für mich ist eine
große Herausforderung
der wir uns im Team stellen wir gehen
sie an mit viel Enthusiasmus mit großer
Vorfreude natürlich auch den nötigen
Verantwortungsbewusstsein wie Rudi
gerade richtig sagt steht da dann seine
Nation dahinter die wir natürlich auch
mit guten Fußball als als gesamte Gruppe
als gesamte Mannschaft auch begeistern
wollen
gut und wenn es geht bitte auch
erfolgreich Boris Büchler ist der Mann
bei uns der die Nationalmannschaft immer
im Auge hat schon und ab nach München
Boris wie war denn die Vorstellung heute
irgendwann was anders war als sonst beim
DFB
ja der nagelsmann der Julian der wirkte
aufgeräumt der wirkte kämpferisch und er
wirkte sehr sehr selbstbewusst und der
DFB hat jetzt endlich mal einen
Bundestrainer der auch medial so richtig
gut wirkt und das wird nicht unwichtig
sein gerade um die Fans wieder
mitzunehmen um die Fans zu begeistern
und bei der 50-minütigen Presse Audienz
war zu jeder Zeit zu spüren hier brennt
jemand für seinen Job und dieser
Enthusiasmus und diese Begeisterung wird
natürlich ganz wichtig sein gerade nach
den trübsinnigen Tagen unter Anblicke es
waren ja noch andere im Vorfeld im
Gespräch aber nagelsmann wird es jetzt
die einen feiern die Entscheidung andere
sind ein bisschen skeptisch ist er denn
deiner Meinung nach der richtige
naja der DFB war in der Vergangenheit
immer mal gut für eine falsche
Personalentscheidung aber diese
Entscheidung diese Personalie sitzt die
ist super gut das haben auch Julian
nagelsmann selbst gesagt heute Mittag
das ist klar aber auch Jürgen Klopp und
Thomas Tuchel und nagelsmann ist meines
Erachtens auf jeden Fall der richtige
Mann am richtigen Posten er ist fachlich
1A er ist innovatives kreativ hat eine
moderne Spielidee dem moderne
Trainingsmethoden und ein riesen Vorteil
ist natürlich dass er aus seiner
Münchner Zeit fast alle Nationalspieler
kennt und aus seiner Leipziger Zeit ja
ich würde mal sagen nagelsmann kann
Bundestrainer aber es gibt natürlich
noch einige Risiken aber jetzt muss er
das auch erstmal noch beweisen jetzt
hast du die Risiken schon angesprochen
welche siehst du denn jetzt bei seiner
Verpflichtung für ihn aber vielleicht
auch für den DFB
nagelsmann ist 36 Jahre alt und gerade
in der Endphase bei Bayern fehlt dem
manchmal so die Souveränität und auch
die Reife man muss ganz klar sagen nach
verlorenen Spielen war er hin und wieder
schon mal patzig und trotzig und
Interviews bei Pressekonferenzen hat
sich schon mal mit dem Schiedsrichter
angelegt und auch mit einigen
Topspielern bei Bayern kann man nicht so
klar mit Lewandowski am Ende mit Thomas
Müller und Manuel Neuer an seinem
Torwarttrainer und viele Schlagzeilen
die er produziert hat waren selbst
verschuldet aber entscheidend heute bei
der Pressekonferenz präsentiert er sich
extrem ja
selbstbewusst aber auch selbstkritisch
hat sogar Fehler eingeräumt die aber
Bayern begangen habe das fand ich sehr
bemerkenswert er gilt und galt er immer
in Deutschland als das größte Trainer
Talent jetzt muss er beweisen dass er
nicht nur talentiert ist sondern auch
ein gereifter und gestandener Trainer
sein kann wir sehen uns dann spätestens
beim ersten Spiel Schlaf vielen Dank
nach München
und wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit
Nachrichten unter anderem aus der
Wirtschaft und mit dir Heinz vor dem
wohnungsbaugipfel im Kanzleramt der
Montag mit bundländern Kommunen und
Verbänden gibt es eine ganze Reihe von
Forderungen und auch Misstöne Sina
meinet wie ist die konkrete Ausgangslage
für dieses Treffen also die Ausgangslage
für den wohnungsgipfel am Montag wie es
denkbar schlecht denn schon bevor er
startet haben die Wohnungswirtschaft und
der eigentümerverband Haus und Grund
ihre Teilnahme abgesagt begründet wird
das unter anderem damit dass die
ampelregierung zu wenig Unternehmen den
Bau und Kauf von Wohneigentum zu fördern
unterdessen schreitet der Wertverlust
auf dem Immobilienmarkt unaufhaltsam
voran im zweiten Quartal dieses Jahres
fielen die Preise umfasst zehn Prozent
verglichen zum Vorjahreszeitraum das ist
das stärkste Minus seit 23 Jahren in den
Städten fehlen die Preise übrigens
stärker als auf dem Land
Häuslebauer sind zurückhaltend und
verunsichert war früher nämlich vor
allem die Lage einer Immobilie
entscheidend ist es heute auch deren
Energieeffizienz hinzu kommen dann eine
unsichere Zinsentwicklung und gestiegene
Baukosten sie machen die Finanzierung
und kalkulierbarer und das
heizungsgesetz verteuere den Neubau noch
zusätzlich sagen Branchenverbände sie
fordern jetzt eine Entlastung bei teuren
Baukosten und Zinsen außerdem
Steuererleichterungen und die
mietpreisbremse auf diesem
wohnungsgipfel wird das Thema auch
steigende Mieten sein denn weil zu wenig
gebaut wird verteuern sich die Mieten
drastisch bis nächstes Jahr werden
außerdem voraussichtlich jährlich nur
halb so viele neue Wohnungen entstehen
wie geplant nämlich nicht 400.000
sondern nur 200.000 baupräsident Peter
Hübner fordert wirklich an allen
Schräubchen für geringere Baukosten zu
drehen jetzt vielen Dank
in Brasilien hat der Oberste Gerichtshof
die rechte indigene Völker gestärkt und
ein Gesetzesvorhaben abgewiesen dass
noch aus der Zeit des rechtsgerichteten
Präsidenten Bol sonado stammt die vom
Gericht abgelehnte Regelung hätte die
Ausweisung von Schutzgebieten für
Ureinwohner stark begrenzt in die Gene
Gruppen feierten die Entscheidung ihre
Schutzgebiete gelten für Experten als
Bollwerk gegen die Abholzung des
Amazonas Regenwaldes
es gibt Glaubensgemeinschaften die Leben
sehr zurückgezogen manche sogar total
abgeschottet die Arme Spiegel gehören
definitiv dazu sie sind täuferisch
protestantisch im 18 Jahrhundert aus
Europa vor Krieg Gewalt und
Unterdrückung geflohen insbesondere
übrigens aus Deutschland und der Schweiz
sie leben streng nach den Regeln des
Neuen Testaments und Lehen weitestgehend
die moderne Technik ab es gibt kein
Internet kein Fernsehen geschweige denn
ein Auto mit Ihnen ins Gespräch zu
kommen bei ihnen zu drehen ist so gut
wie unmöglich daher ist es umso
bemerkenswerter dass Barbara Völkel
genau das gelungen ist
wer den Amis begegnet taucht in eine
vergangene Welt ein die Täufer des
protestantische Glaubensgemeinschaft kam
vor über 300 Jahren aus Europa in die
USA hier in Ohio lebt eine der weltweit
größten Amis Gemeinden
sie tragen altmodische Kleidung und
lange Bärte und lehnen weitestgehend den
technischen Fortschritt wie Elektrizität
Internet und Autos ab sie sind auch
selbst Versorger wie der 40-Jährige Ines
Label aus mittelfield Amisch in vierter
Generation seine Vorfahren kam aus
Süddeutschland er verdient sein Geld als
Pharma und Hufschmied und lebt mit
seiner Frau und den sieben Kindern auf
einer fast 40 Hektar großen Farben
die Arme ist der alten Ordnung sind
pferdeorientiert wir benutzen keine
Autos und Traktoren
das ist unsere Lebensweise
doch die moderne Welt ist eine
Herausforderung für die
Glaubensgemeinschaft und im
Geschäftsleben der Amis nicht mehr
wegzudenken denn laut einer neuen Studie
leben etwa nur noch sieben Prozent
ausschließlich von der Landwirtschaft
das weiß auch Chester kurz der Amish ist
Vater von sieben Kindern und kein Pharma
sondern Bauleiter und vermittelt
Handwerker in seinem Büro ist er auf die
moderne Technik angewiesen
für die Arbeit ist es erlaubt wenn ich
es selbst nicht besitze zu Hause nein
heuchlerisch findet er die Lebensweise
der Amish Alter Ordnung aber nicht nur
weil sie in ihren Geschäften die moderne
Technik verwenden dürfen zu Hause aber
nicht
wenn wir strenge starre Regeln hätten
und unseren Lebensunterhalt immer noch
so verdienen würden wie im 18
Jahrhundert könnten wir nicht
konkurrieren wenn wir versuchen würden
mit Handsägen hämmern und Nägeln Häuser
zu bauen dann hätten wir keine Arbeit
ja nicht alle Gemeinden sind
gleichstreng in der Beibehaltung der
alten Traditionen die Amis sind
kinderreich weil Verhütung zum Beispiel
verboten ist und doch erlauben es manche
Gemeinden wie bei Ätna die bereits sechs
Kinder hat
wir haben einfach beschlossen dass es
reicht und haben Verhütungsmaßnahmen
ergriffen
ich möchte nicht das Bild zeichnen dass
die Armee perfekte kleine fromme
Menschen sind das sind sie nicht immer
denn es gibt Fälle von Inzest unter den
armischen das ist sehr traurig
die größten Gemeinden befinden sich in
Indianer Ohio und Pennsylvania dort
leben nach neuesten Studien mehr als
377.000 armisch bei einer jährlichen
Wachstumsrate von mehr als drei Prozent
beträgt die Population 2038 über eine
halbe Million
ihr wirtschaftlich unabhängiges Leben
ist moderner geworden ihren Grundsätzen
und Werten aber sind sie treu es bleibt
ein vorbestimmtes und abgeschiedenes
Leben von der Außenwelt
seltene Einblicke wie seltene Bilder die
Dokumentation von Barbara Völkel das
Leben der Amisch am Sonntag auf Arte um
19.30 und bereits jetzt schon in der
Mediathek und um 0 Uhr 20 meldet sich
also in Götte mir mit unserem heute
schnell Update und wir dann morgen
wieder wünschen Ihnen an dieser Stelle
einen schönen Abend machen sie es gut wo
auch immer Sie sind
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter hier schauen wir
auf die Chronik der
Oberflächentemperatur in den Weltmeeren
und was Sie hier sehen ist seit
1981 die Zunahme der Temperaturen mit
der globalen Erhitzung aber was sie noch
sehen ist das aktuelle Jahr 2023 was
hier deutlich von allem abweicht was wir
bisher hatten und seit März auf
Rekordkurse ist und zu warme Meere und
Ozeane bedeuten Futter für die
Extremwetterereignisse weltweit derzeit
haben wir es eher mit ruhigen Wetter zu
tun sind einige Schauer und Gewitter
dabei die ziehen aber allmählich
ostwärts und lösen sich auf und dann
kommt ein hoch und nächste Woche wird es
wieder wärmer und vor allem trockener
wir schauen auf die Nacht und da sind
hier noch Schauer und Gewitter über der
Mitte vor allem dann noch unterwegs ist
verlagert sich ostwärts in den
Frühstunden bildet sich Nebel und ganz
im Süden da regnet es die Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf 5 Grad in der Eifel und
12 Grad zum Beispiel an der Ostsee und
morgen ganz im Süden weiterhin etwas
Regenschauer sind auch dabei neue shower
und Gewitter dann im Nordwesten
dazwischen häufig sonnig aber hier und
da kann es auch mal tröpfeln meistens
ist eigentlich trocken bei Temperaturen
von 21° im Osten und 12 Grad am
Alpenrand und die nächsten Tage viel
Sonnenschein wieder dabei Sonntag bis 22
Grad und schauen Sie auf den Dienstag
bis 28 Grad fahren ein schönen Abend